Do you know we've talked a lot on this show
about vintage shopping for clothes?
It's made a huge comeback.
But it's not just for clothes,
people are doing it with other things too.
"Vogue" reports the secondhand market for furniture
is really on fire.
Online resellers, like Chairish,
say business has grown 60%, Drew.
People want cheaper, sustainable furnishings,
and they don't care if it's brand new.
It's a great way to find special items at a discount.
I do this all the time in Palm Springs.
I'm always on the lookout for like a vintage chair.
Well, that's a great destination for vintage shopping.
Totally, I even bought a pickup, Drew.
Do you know I drive a pickup, mm-hmm,
in Palm Springs, oh, yeah.
Can we put like a just married sign on it
with a bunch of the cans hanging off the back?
Please.
I'll decorate it.
Okay, with the leftover flowers.
Yeah.
But I do, I love it.
I love finding a one of a kind piece.
You know?
Yeah.
I found these end tables
at a thrift store called Angel View.
It's a charity thrift store.
And I bought them for like $35,
and then I Googled them
and they were worth like almost $1,000.
You know, you can find amazing things out in the world
if you just sort of go through the stores.
Clap of hands, who's into vintage shopping?
Oh, yeah.
(audience clapping)
Clap of hands, who is like,
"I am not putting my butt on that used couch?"
(small group clapping)
I like it, ladies.
And you're like really in cahoots about it, which is great.
(upbeat music)